Nintendo is finally released details
about the first DLC pack for breath of
the wild but there are plenty of things
that we still don't know such as will
there be any more sexy armor for link
and where can I find said sexy armor I
only ask the important questions so grab
your sword put your theory crafting caps
on and make sure to catch up on our
series of the things that we wish we
knew before playing breath of the wild
one of the main draws for this DLC is
what they're calling trial of the sword
which appears to be a horde style
challenge mode in which they State Link
will face an onslaught of enemies one
wave after another you won't get any
weapons or gear to start out with in the
photo on Nintendo's website link can be
seen wearing just as shorts with the
tree branch and must clear all 45 rooms
and by beating this mode you'll be able
to power up the Master Sword again the
website reads the power of the Master
Sword will be awakened and it will
always be in its glowing powerup state
while usable okay first off there is no
way Nintendo would give the Master Sword
unlimited power it has to still have
that 10 minute cooldown or else that
whole thing about the weapon system
being balanced just goes right out the
window my guess is that it will still
power down after a certain amount of use
but when you do use it it will always be
at 60 attack instead of losing the glow
and dropping to 30 instead not a bad
reward at all but what intrigues me the
most is that the trial is located in
what they're calling a certain sacred
location now based on the screenshots
the trial looks to be in some sort of
shrine encounter so it could be anywhere
from the Lost Woods to the seven
heroines to maybe even on a vent eyed
island but what about this store a
Reddit user found this at the very top
of Hyrule Castle and it's got a Triforce
on it and everything
if only we had the tingle tuner to help
us find the entrance and speaking of
things to find it looks like we're going
to have some new armor pieces available
to us hidden in treasure chests placed
around Hyrule well Nintendo never said
this would be easy in addition to the
correct masks that will assist us in
finding hidden seeds by vibrating when
there's one nearby
there's headgear from both Majora's Mask
and Twilight Princess a full gear set
from Phantom Hourglass
and wait is that is that oh god stop the
presses
cancel all my meetings and forget the
rest of this DLC the tingle
is all I need in my life oh there
there's still more features fine we'll
do that but that's right back to tingle
okay ah anyway
Nintendo hasn't said exactly what the
gear will do or if they'll even do
anything at all but I'd love to see
something Moon related with Majora's
Mask like every time you put it on it
will cause a Blood Moon to rise the
Minda helmet is a little bit more
complicated because she has so many
different powers but maybe even
something like a locator for treasures
like they do with the shrines would be
cool the phantom armor could be a
defense heavy set I mean just look at it
it's all as a rock right and the tingle
outfit aside from making every single
one of us uncomfortably excited could
have some cool perks like more selfie
poses or an increased rupee draw or even
a fairy detector the sky's the limit
would tingle it's anyone's guess as to
what they will actually do but I'll give
you the Tendo the benefit of the doubt
and hopefully we'll be treated to some
awesome new abilities with this gear
there's also a mode included in this DLC
called heroes path it's kind of a nifty
addition as it tracks links location and
movement throughout Hyrule over the last
200 hours played but that's kind of it I
guess it's kind of cool if you like
seeing where you've been and where you
haven't Nintendo seems to be touting
this as a way to help people find more
shrines in the game but what about those
who have already found them all if we're
talking about completionists here the
hero's path doesn't seem to have much to
offer to them other than a glorified GPS
tracker and same goes with the travel
medallion with it we'll be able to set
our current location as a quick travel
spot so if you found an awesome area to
farm some durians but a shrine is
nowhere to be found
you can use the medallion and then come
back as often as you'd like but only one
location can be saved and not only that
we're gonna have to find it first - oh
we're just not getting any freebies in
this DLC and last but not least is the
DLC feature we've all been talking about
hard mode since Nintendo did release
some details there isn't a whole lot to
speculate about but let's take a look
anyway so in addition to having every
enemy powered up by one level so for
example red enemies become blue blue
become black etc etc they also
regenerate health over time making
fights against stronger enemies even
tougher we're all going to have a field
day with whatever the Silver Line will
turn
probably a gold one right but enemies on
the ground will be the least of our
worries
because they've actually taken to the
skies in this mode the preview photo
shows mob woods suspended high in the
air by octoroks
just waiting to be blown off by a
Corrick leaf but hear me out what if
there were bigger more intricate
structures that haven't been shown yet
like giant flying airships filled with
Bob Lin's tossing explosive barrels and
throwing spears that sounds like a
challenge
now I'd love to do some more analysis on
tingles outfit but I've got other work
to do so if you've got any ideas as to
what the armor does or what we can
expect from trial of the sword put it in
the comments below and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for even more
breath of the wild videos
[Music]